one of the most talented at his position
in the game and he's back here on the
rich eisen show fresh off of a
13 catch 196 yard performance against
the houston texans getting set to take
on
the minnesota vikings and try and sweep
the season series and potentially nail
shut
their 20 20 hopes we have devonte adams
of the packers back here on the show how
are you sir
i'm doing great how you doing i am doing
better for talking to you
um do you do you know
first throw from aaron rodgers in a day
that okay this is gonna be a day
like the one that you had do you get
that sense right off the bat
devonte well i think it's i think it's
when we get off to the type of start
that we did that's what kind of lets me
know
the first ball isn't usually an
indicator but um
mentality wise you know as soon as i get
my hand on that ball if it's early i
feel like this is the type of day we're
gonna have you know especially when
you know what type of defense you're
going up against and you know what they
like to do
so um it's just about capitalizing on
those opportunities but yeah you get you
get a couple of them early you can
definitely start getting your mindset on
that
because i hear so many times watching a
game and also talking to
uh my guy michael irvin on the set you
got to get your star receiver
in the mix right away you got to get
that guy right away so there is some
credence to that
you're saying yeah absolutely yeah yeah
once you get i feel like just mentality
wise
and i mean you look at the numbers i
mean i've never done it but
i feel like you know if when you get a
you know you're number one going early
and he's able to get his hands on the
balls and be able to make some impact
plays
i want to say that it has to be pretty
good as far as you know the
at least the the production by the
offense if not you know the entire team
and you know
ultimately equating to win so um you
know anytime that i can
put on for the team and do as much as i
can with the ball um i think it'll put
us in a good spot
and let's be honest with each other
devonte and i'm not just saying this is
because i don't want to call anybody out
say on houston
maybe you didn't have that feeling this
past week but when you do catch your
first ball if not your second on
somebody that you know you
you you you've got him that's happened
before right yeah
right the defender oh absolutely tip i
mean typically when uh you know at the
start of a game
you know just based off how they come
out confidence wise how did how they
decided to play me i
typically know how the matchup will go
but obviously we know football is the
most team game that there is so at the
end of the day
it's a lot of things that go into you
know me being able to put up 200 yards
but
um anytime anytime we can do that and
potentially you know give me some shots
early uh
i feel like it's a recipe for for
success so um
what is it like because i you know uh
it's been
last season in this season where you got
hurt and
watching what is it like for you to
watch i know you were pushing to get
back in
um getting back in obviously against
uh tampa you got back in but before that
you were trying to get back in with your
injury and the team was kind
of holding you out similar to what they
did to aaron jones this past week
what does that look like what is that
like i mean it's painful man for a
competitor a guy who obviously is leaned
on to make a lot of plays for this team
it's tough to sit back and watch but um
i mean
honestly it's it's been it's been a
little bit of a blessing in disguise
just for the
the entire team because i feel like it's
allowed some other guys to
get some opportunities that they may not
have had if i was in there the whole
time and
gave them some options to show the
coaching staff what they're about and i
think a lot of guys like alan lazard
has stepped up in some of those moments
he's obviously injured right now but
last year my absence and this year he
was able to do some stuff
in that saints game had a really big
game so give some other guys some some
option allows me to kind of coaching
and you know just leave with a little
bit of wisdom and you know experience on
the sideline
coach walk me through coach adams what
does coach adam sound like
what's that like man well it's not a lot
of yelling because these guys make it
easy for me
as a vet you know it's obviously this is
the most distance as far as years that
we've probably had in this room in a
long time so um you know
those guys go out there they watch how i
do it and they watch
you know just just how to go about their
business and the right way and i feel
like that that makes it just based off
how they practice it makes it a million
times easier for the game so
um it's pretty easy i just got to kind
of throw my pointers in there off based
off what i'm seeing and uh
yeah hopefully we don't have to do too
much of that so i can coach while i'm
playing
because that's that's a little bit more
fun for me devonte adams three-time pro
bowl wide receiver of the green bay
packers back here on the rich eisen show
and you are a perfect person to ask this
question to
because as you know the draft narrative
was no help for aaron no help as a
matter of fact they draft
his potential successor no help for
aaron at the wide receiver position in
the deepest wide receiver draft we've
seen
for quite some time how did that
criticism land in the wide receiver room
devonte um well one i'm gonna correct
you just a quick correction
best best receiver class maybe since my
class i got to throw that in my bad let
me write that down
let me write that down okay but um i
mean it was
you know it was obviously a little bit
of a shock to everybody um it was no
surprise that just based off of
you know some some needs that we had
some guys that could potentially help us
or
a position that we could potentially get
some help and um
take us to that next level after being
so close last year you know it was
definitely a thought in everyone's mind
that we do that but
just the way we do it the pack of ways
just to buy in and trust it so i think
today i mean
um you know we we've trusted it we love
jordan and we've
welcomed him and um he's done a great
job since he's been here so
um same with aaron he he kind of took
him in just how he has anybody else
since he's been here and um
you know you can see the the evolution
now with jordan he's even gotten that
much better since he's been here so
um as we continue to push you know
whatever happens in the receiver room
uh you know whatever happens happens but
the end of the day everybody who's in
there now is ready to play
well i'm not asking about the
quarterback situation i'm talking about
how people thought the wide receiver
room needed more help
for aaron rodgers that's the that's what
i was talking about people said that
people say that but at the end of the
day i mean you look at the numbers you
look at these games that we've had
and uh you know we've been we've been
able to take care of some business
obviously the more depth that you can
have the better
off you'll be but you know as long as we
got the guys that we got i'll go to
battle with them any day so
i'm not really too worried about the
outside noise but that's just kind of
how we do it whoever is you know
whoever's in there is is got to step it
up and uh
fill those shoes well we had aaron
rodgers on the show just a couple weeks
ago devonte and i asked him that very
same question
and his response was laden filled
with um the history of grievances that
every wide receiver could have had about
their play
that was incorrect i mean he literally
went through the litany of lazard in
particular about his history
of first being a tight end and then
jacksonville let him go
and then he couldn't get on the field
with green bay i mean he knew literally
every aspect of his personal career path
and i'm wondering what that means
for you in the rest of that room well i
mean just shows that
how invested he is i mean a guy that
caliber
isn't typically expected to know certain
things like that especially
as it pertains to things that were
before stepping into this building so
just shows how how invested he is into
his guys and even guys who
the whole world may not know um he knows
those specific details that i feel like
honestly
it ultimately ends up allowing you to
have a closer connection on the field so
that's just the type of guy is and it
also says a lot about aaron as far as
just
his memory i mean because there's a lot
of a lot of things that he brings up and
i see it on the field a lot where he'll
give me a signal of something that we
haven't done since you know camp of my
second year here so
um just his memory is pretty sharp there
too so i think it says a lot about both
of those guys all right i gotta pull on
that string a little bit here what do
you mean what do you mean he'll
bring something up like that walk me
through that a little more devante
well i mean you know just just like a
signal or something that he told me
based off of a play that he saw week
seven in 2015
he'll he'll you know we'll go through
walkthroughs right now and he'll see
that same look now
give me the signal and see if i run it
the you know the proper way based off
how he coached it years ago
and it's kind of like a little bit of a
test um
you know to see exactly how sharp i
guess the wide outs are as well but
but on top of it i think he's also
starting to stretch out his mind a
little bit and that's kind of how he
stays sharp by
you know running himself through those
exercises every now and then no kidding
so when you say a test it's it's
something that you know that he's kind
of
uh playing a three-dimensional game of
chess inspiring
as well as making sure yours just as
sharp like literally
correct it's also a little bit of a read
because based off how he plays you know
aaron's just you know he plays fast so
um he may give you a signal he wants to
see how it hits your brain based off of
the coverage so
you know it may be something that we've
gone over and and we have a different
look and he wants he'll signal it to me
to see
you know what is tay gonna do based off
of this look and then you know based off
of whatever i do
um you know i'll look back and see his
reaction in the walkthrough if i get a
thumbs up and i know
we know we're on the same page mentally
and if he's kind of looking at me i go
back talk to him and we figure out how
to
you know make sure we both are on the
same page with that but it's it's
typically just something he just wants
to test out and see
um before we get out there on the field
but sometimes you'll get the one on the
field as well i see
i love this devonte uh devante adams
here i love this because basically
you're saying
your your pro bowl relationship is still
growing with him and aaron
i mean every day every day honestly
because it just happened about
25 minutes ago same thing so it's a
little sharper in my mind because
that exact thing just happened so um and
it's fun for me just because
you know sometimes i get a signal i'll
be like in my head i'm thinking this guy
thinks i don't know what i'm doing right
now watch this and i get out there and i
just
pull off a double move and he's looking
at me smiling with a thumbs up and i'm
like okay well
i feel like we just took another step
closer to um
not perfection but just continue to
strive for that devante adams here on
the rich eisen show you've been on some
teams with some championship caliber
one was obviously last year what what
feeling do you get right now entering
week eight against minnesota
devonte i get a lot of the same feelings
man honestly rich is it's um
you know it's a lot of the same players
um the same mindset but just with
a little bit more hunger than last year
i think just we got a little bit of a
sour taste in our mouth based off of how
we ended the season we obviously
did a lot of good things finished the
regular season 13 and three which is an
amazing
feat when you have a brand new head
coach and you don't you know everybody's
buying in trying to you know
all get on the same page together and
then we we finished up the season strong
like that
um you know and we were one step away
from getting there so
i think everybody's mentality is is kind
of you know on the same wavelength that
we left off
left off on but um just a little bit
more hungry than where we
were last year and again um is rogers
any different he said he worked on
himself this off season when he
explained to me a few weeks i mean i i
see i just see a
elevated version of himself it's just
you know everything just from positivity
just his morale
i mean he's throwing the ball extremely
well he's leading the team i missed two
games and
he went out there and balled out without
me so i think it's it's pretty
self-explanatory when you look at the
numbers and how he's playing
he's playing mvp caliber season um
never want to get too too far ahead of
ourselves obviously but
the way that man's ball him right now uh
i just suggest people just stay out of
his way
okay and uh before i let you go um i
don't mean any disrespect to your
quarterback or you
when i ask this question how about that
for um to set up the question
but let's just say uh aaron throws a
pick six right on the goal line
uh how many yards would you have to give
buddha baker as a heads uh
uh of head start before you run him down
devonta
i don't i don't know if i'm getting him
the way dk did i'm not even gonna sit
here and lie to you i don't know if i'm
getting them the way
he looked like julio like i don't want
to say on steroids because i don't want
to get that man
a random drug test right but he was he
looked like a gazelle chasing down
and usually gazelles aren't the ones
chasing stuff but he looked like a
gazelle chasing a lion
so i don't know if that's ever happened
before but that was it no i know you're
very confident in your abilities
uh as you corrected me earlier in this
conversation that your draft class is
the greatest
the wide receiver class i picked up on
that but but dk metcalf you're saying
that was
particularly something that maybe you
might not even be able to
uh run down is what you're saying that
that is that is special there i would
say him
tyreek hill and uh and and maybe uh
i don't know that's that's only two
people i could say right now anybody
else got to prove it at this point but
um maybe maybe like a marquis goodwin
speed something like that something one
of those guys can go ahead and get that
i'ma chase his butt down but
i don't know if i'm gonna hawk him with
a with a 20 yard head start on me well
not just that you got to be able to make
the tackle at the end
too you got it you got to tackle him and
you know he wasn't even close to scoring
that's the thing that's that's what
really got me i think
buddha looked back at him and he made it
he may have had a little
a little cut across the field a little
swerving or something had he known but
i don't really blame him because it's
not any there's not supposed to be
anybody that can run that fast and get
down there that quickly so
the end of the day we'll just say good
play to buddha yes you gotta just gotta
tip your cap
so who's the fastest on your team who
might be able to pull that off would you
be or is there somebody else would you i
wouldn't i wouldn't say i'm the fastest
i would i'd say it's probably it'd
probably come down to like a
like a marquez or uh you know jayer is
pretty fast too
um what about aaron jones what about
aaron jones
aaron jones is fast but i don't even
think i could say aaron jones faster
than me man i mean he's gonna have to
race me and prove that
but i don't i don't know he he's broke
some but uh
you know i don't know if he got me just
yet we'll see
devante i love our chats i really
appreciate you giving time um
let's chat down the road i appreciate
the call thank you absolutely rich
appreciate it right back at you that's
one of the best in the business devonte
adams
even tipping his cap to dk metcalf